foreign
for a second that your job was made
redundant by an advanced piece of
software that could do the work at the
same level of quality
for free
but you happen to have three years left
on a guaranteed contract and so your
employer gives you two options
either you can keep getting paid as per
your contract but stay home as the
software does your job
or you can keep going in and doing the
work that could have been automated for
the same money
what would you do now most of you I'm
sure this is a no-brainer take the money
go home watch TED talks
but there's always some who would choose
to keep working
what do you think of those people
what does it say about their character
this is the scenario about a
hypothetical medical scribe named Jeff
that we gave to our research
participants
for half the people in the study the
story ends with Jeff choosing to go home
and for the other half it ends with him
choosing to keep working
and then we asked everybody what they
thought of Jeff
those who heard about the Jeff who kept
working
saw him as less competent
he does seem like a bit of a chump
but they also saw him as warmer and more
moral
somebody who could be trusted to do the
right thing
they saw him as a good person
even though Jeff added no extra value
people saw him as virtuous for choosing
to keep plugging away
why is it that we see mere effort as
moral
I am a psychology professor at the
University of British Columbia where I
study morality I've worked on religion
and morality I've worked on driverless
cars and morality
but recently my collaborators and I have
been working on work itself
and in study after study we find that
people attach more worth
to effort regardless of what that effort
produces
so in another study we asked people
about two widget makers they produce the
same number of widgets in the same
amount of time at the same level of
quality but for one of them it takes a
lot more effort to do so people see that
harder working widget maker as again
less competent
but again more moral and if you had to
choose just one of those two as a
cooperation partner you would choose the
one who struggles
we call this effort moralization
and it doesn't appear to just be a North
American thing work Norms of course
differ around the world but we
replicated our original American result
in South Korea which is known by the
numbers to be one of the hardest working
countries in the oecd
and in France
which is known for other strengths
in all of these places the harder
working person was seen as more moral
and a better cooperation partner even
though they added no extra value
and it looks like this is something
broader than say the Protestant work
ethic even the hadza people
hunter-gatherers in Tanzania show
something like it
when asked what qualities contribute to
good character they didn't agree on very
much but they did agree on two things
generosity
and hard work
so this intuitive connection between
effort and morality doesn't appear to be
The Quirk of any one culture but
potentially something very deep indeed
now effort moralization makes sense at
the individual level somebody who's
willing to show that they will put
effort into even meaningless tasks maybe
even especially into meaningless tasks
is somebody who's more likely to help
you out
so I have a a friend from work Paul
is an uncommonly charismatic man Paul
wears stylish pairs of raw denim jeans
and Paul buys expensive bars of soap
sixty dollar bars of soap
and Paul is one of those types who wakes
up every morning and goes running
and when I first heard this I sort of
rolled my eyes at this being one of
those Mr Perfect things
actually Dr perfect in this case
but then one day I saw Paul on one of
his morning runs and instead of seeing a
Sleek type A personality confidently
striding through life I saw Paul
struggling in an inelegant hobble
with a grotesque Grimace of something
between annoyance and Agony on his face
running was hard for him every morning
was effort
and the person who's willing to wake up
for that day after day is the kind of
person you want in your corner
and Paul isn't mine
he's not just the inspiration behind
some of the studies in this research he
is a collaborator on them as well
and he's a good man
the truth is we're all in the market for
finding the best collaborators in life
and we're trying to show others that we
are that person as well
The evolutionary psychologists call this
partner choice
just as we're trying to be and select
the best romantic Partners we're also
trying to be and select the best
cooperation partners
we're all trying to surround ourselves
with people who will help us out in the
pinch who won't slack off who will share
things fairly and as a result any
quality which makes you a better
cooperation partner
say generosity or self-control or hard
work
is seen as a moral quality
and so we have this simple heuristic
people who work hard
are good
it's why you're more likely to donate to
your friend who pledges to run a
marathon for cancer research then your
other friend who pledges to watch a sex
in the city marathon for the same cause
but what makes sense at the individual
level can still become very problematic
when scaled up to the societal level our
intuition that effort is good for its
own sake regardless of what it produces
has created a work environment with
perverse incentives
so when we start attaching Worth to
activity rather than to productivity we
start caring more about whether somebody
is a hard worker
then whatever it is that that work was
supposed to achieve
and this can come at a very steep human
cost
so you'll remember our example of Jeff
the medical scribe who chose to throw
his time into the volcano is a sacrifice
to the gods of hard work
that was just a contrived scenario
but how many Jeffs are out there taking
time that could have been spent on love
or on leisure
and spending it on signaling effort and
how often are we Jeff
wearing workaholism is a badge of honor
a way to reassure people that we are a
good person
even if the person you're just trying to
reassure is yourself
the Anthropologist David Graber wondered
how capitalism could sustain so many of
what he bluntly called jobs
these are jobs in which even the people
doing the work see it as pointless
accomplishing nothing of societal worth
capitalistic system should root out
those inefficiencies
but it doesn't
and the reason it doesn't is because
alongside capitalism we also operate on
under another system
what the journalist Derek Thompson calls
workism
workism is about your job not just being
the source of your paycheck
but the source of your identity and your
pathway to self-actualization
now that works for some people
but what makes workism a culture
is that we all get forced to participate
partner choice is not just about being a
good cooperation partner but a better
cooperation partner than the next guy
not just hard working but harder working
and this can create These Arms races of
workism
so you can imagine two office workers
both Keen to show how industrious they
are both Keen to be the first car in the
parking lot in the morning
and so they start one-upping each other
by arriving earlier and earlier and
earlier in the morning
and everybody else just seems like more
of a slacker every day
the culture punishes us for not keeping
up and so we end up putting more and
more in regardless of what comes out the
other side
and the culture maintains the most
laborious aspects of our jobs
because it most appreciates us when it
sees us putting in that labor and as a
consequence every other aspect of our
job and our lives however great
is made just a little less important
now this is not an argument against hard
work it's not hard work can be extremely
meaningful when it serves a purpose hard
work built civilization
but how much of the effort we spend now
is done to build nothing but our own
moral reputations to just convince other
people that we are hard workers
and how much of what we admire in others
is just effort porn
in one of his more candid moments one of
my graduate students said that he
noticed
I would send emails out at all hours of
the day 1am 2 A.M 3 A.M
now this was because being a professor
allowed me to maintain an adolescent
sleep schedule deep into my 30s
I did was he got some app
which scheduled his replies to come to
me at one or two in the morning so as to
make it seem like he was also working
all hours of the day
I clearly sent the wrong message so much
so that my student was willing to delay
the work to make it seem like he was
more industrious it was literally
work
I had to change my lab's culture I had
to convince my students
now we weren't just about the show of
work but what we're actually producing
and it's not such a simple thing to do
the mental circuit that connects effort
to morality can be a stubborn one
when I teach about psychological biases
to my intro psych students I tell them
that you can't always learn to resist a
bias they can be very deeply ingrained
but you can learn to notice them so that
you can account for them when making
important decisions we may not be able
to break that mental circuit but we can
learn to recognize our biases so they
did don't run our lives
there's a story almost certainly
apocryphal about perverse incentives in
the era of British rule in India
desperate to deal with the cobras that
were overrunning colonial Delhi a bounty
was put up for every Cobra skin that was
brought in but the plan backfired
because enterprising Indians started
breeding more cobras to kill them bring
in the skins and collect the Bounty and
when the government finally abandoned
the plan as The Story Goes the Breeders
then released the cobras into the City
and the snake problem was worse than
ever
oops
the plan went awry because of the
distance between what they wanted which
was fewer cobras and what they asked for
which was an imperfect signal of fewer
cobras dead cobras
but I fear we've done something
very real and very similar with work
we have built a culture that asks for
the wrong thing
if all we ask from each other is the
effort that we put in
we will create a world full of effort
and of hard labor
and of cobras
but if what we ask from each other is to
produce something meaningful
we will create a world full of meaning
and what could be more moral than that
thank you
[Applause]